you want to get me coaching on a game my
inventor then show me your form yeah
I can give you coaching now
do you need to see push-ups no I'll be
fine okay so so I could like drop down
into town on move one well yeah we start
the clock and then you just decide when
you want to do that you can do it
anytime you want but you have to do it
50 or 60 60 60. okay so let's go we've
grown
oh
[Music]
right
our Bishops yeah I did not pace myself
though no no oh my goodness we were in
this spot
more push-ups all right
it's pretty even position
so I'm gonna like go here
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
advantage over us all night you're gonna
use that against us
my arms hurt
thank you
oh I have to play faster
another three minute is
spicy
[Music]
yeah you can just do that though it was
a cool move
but it was a button
[Music]
no no no no no no no
what all right I got it for three
minutes at least I did my push-ups
what a tragic way to end the game
we've got the oh
[Music]
yeah
we're gonna play in a minute I gotta tag
in and play Canty here yes we have to
take a long time
[Music]
thank you